what
um
[Music]
these are some racist
zombies
[Applause]
a one admission for the continental
breakfast you can just help yourself sir
interesting European style
foreign
[Music]
in Rome
the forbidden fruit
well aren't you a tiny plum
[Music]
well la di da
vapor and everything
and who are you my little friend
not a spoon not a fork but something in
between a fupoon
hey you guys got one of those you know
it's one of those big bags with a dollar
sign on the side of it okay
yeah
you're gonna shoot Arrows with shotgun
shells attached to them to a bank window
to blow out the glass then you're going
to shoot a zip line through that window
and you're going to slide on into the
hallway you're going to be wearing
roller skates so you can just skate on
past the armed guards who will be
shooting at you and you're going to hope
that they both won't hit your legs and
if they are aiming at your torso the
suit of medieval armor will deflect the
bullets then you're going to hope to
gather enough speed to burst through the
big bank vault at the end of the hallway
where you're going to collect the money
in a cartoon money bag
for Christmas and I think I'll take my
business elsewhere it's a Merry
Christmas
it's April
like a low risk opportunity so I'm
looking forward to it we'll see all
right gentlemen take care see you soon
now take care all right man all right
take care see you
I'm a lefty so
Marcus Williams University of Georgia
T.J Jackson Wayne State University
tavariousness King Merrimack College
Utah Royal Smoochy Wallace University
Miami the squarius green Junior
University of Notre Dame Ibrahim was
Zeus University of Tennessee at
Chattanooga Jack Mary's Tech theratrix
Michigan State University
Billings Club High Coastal Carolina
University the Jeff for probing Crooks
III
South Carolina State University
Leos Maxwell jillions East Carolina
University
jamaris Jamar jamaris and Lamar
University of Middle Tennessee
devoine shower handle
University of Southern Mississippi
kringleberry Penn State University
Mr Garvey
what is a a Ron some of us need to leave
a few minutes early today
oh
is that so
and what
pray tell
is the reason
for this premature Exodus
yearbook photos
um we used to leave 15 minutes early to
meet up with our clubs
all right you know what that might work
with other substitute teachers but I
taught him in the city for over 20 years
now y'all want to leave my class early
so y'all can go meet up at the club
ain't none of y'all old enough to go to
the damn Club
ridiculous
Mr Garvey God son of a
did I
Dr just then yes I know I'm in the
minority here but I don't really like
the Christopher Nolan Batman movies I
don't I really just feel like they're
overrated
okay
well that's um
that's just an opinion you see that's
why I prefaced it by saying I know I'm
in the minority
or you know what no no
not really it's not awkward at least not
until you said awkward now it's awkward
because of what you said
anyway anyway what anyway what really
because when you say anyway then you
have to follow it up with an actual
contribution to the conversation we're
having
yeah no look at me look at me look at me
look at me look at me there's no yikes
and the reason why there's no yikes is
there's nothing scary about this
situation okay it's a very low stake
situation all right scurvy nope Ricketts
what no consumption no Mr Washington
something from this Century
schizophrenia no you don't have
schizophrenia keep it simple please
what the hell is that I don't know what
that is it's a fish hook in my lip just
pick something off this list I can't
reach it why not paralyzed
does your face hurt Mr Washington yeah
then this should help
[Music]
unbelievable
Ultra I have a huge problem with this
dish
it's that you haven't made it for me
sooner
Thank You Cher
because if you had Drew then I would
know how good you are at cooking food
that's bad
I'm sorry Chef when I say bad I mean
Michael Jackson Bad
thank you Chef you know how we look
really really bad at the end of his life
I'm sorry I don't know if you like the
dish or not
friend me doing my chest he's freaked on
the middle son
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah yo yo hold up man come on wait
wait what just take this upside down son
to the side a little bit too oh bro my
bad dog my bad dog you wanna keep doing
it let's go
yeah man I'm just I'm saying yo be
careful I got you dog I got you
[Music]
what's up yeah straight down the middle
son you can't go back middle now son
what you already committed to the upside
down and to the side
[Applause]
what are you doing man you said upside
down and to the side that's three omegas
oh man I forgot the pie
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
oh Brothers brothers look at yourself
pants hanging off your ass looking like
a couple of clowns which you are okay
enjoy the birthday celebration
and Tyrell about to come out here right
now
yo Tyrell y'all what up Lauren hey man
you want to play front hand back here I
don't know that game man it's easy dog
all you gotta do is stay front hand the
backhand all right front hands
bam I got you sucker
backhand
[Music]
huh it's still my move right I choose
backhand this time
really back hand
s
look Tom I'm sorry but I ain't sorry you
know what I mean I mean you asked for it
I mean you literally asked for it
right hand what no why you wanna hit him
got it I figured it out front hand no
backhand backhand this Saturday night
this is not even gonna be a fight I'm on
mercy kill this old man
but soon he will learn Madness
I will torture his body
so that his soul learns to be humble I'm
gonna dance around him while he tried to
hit me with his Cane oh man
God trust me for this fight
God is the teacher Derek is the student
and I am God's instrument
when I squeeze your lungs Derek and you
beg me for life
then your heart will open up to the Lord
I'm going to knock him out round one
wait
what did he say again
he said God chose him
that's a
doesn't even make sense really when you
eat through plastic too
when you are paralyzed from neck down
then your family
will gather around your hospital bed
to see the new day
okay he know we just talking here right
I don't care what Plantation I end up on
I'm straight staging a revoke in this
Hills yeah we have lot a
Lot B and Lot C three dollars
four dollars five five dollars going
once twice three times sold laude goes
to the man and the Black Panther
I mean good yeah I'm glad I didn't get
sold because I don't want to be owned by
another human being whoever buys me they
better kill me the first day I'm gonna
go buck wild on the whole operation next
one get up on up there now
oh it's okay
six dollars on lot a seven dollars eight
nine nine dollar going once twice three
times sold
okay well you have to buy that dude it's
a no-brainer I mean that guy's huge
massive individuals that's two of me
anybody would buy him I'd buy that dude
guys hey guys
hey guys oh thank God
and we started a community of survivors
y'all come live with us
[Music]
wait how did you know
come on redneck wants us to move into
his community
us
let's go
over here oh thank God there are others
would you let me date your daughter of
course
[Music]
we gotta go through them just stay
together keep moving and don't get bit
go
are you getting this your what is up all
right let's go
crazy
[Music]
what
um
[Music]
these are some racist
zombies why would you even lock the door
I mean the window's broken oh
oh oh hell no no no no no
[Music]